what i want to do in this video is think
about a fairly traditional business i am
going into the orange juice business
right over here i've written the gallons
of orange juice i am going to produce
each week so all of this is going to be
on a per week basis this is my fixed
cost so i'm assuming it's going to cost
me a thousand dollars and let's say that
that's the rent for this super robotic
orange juicer that i bought that can
really uh that and through that for the
sake of simplicity we're assuming that
we can put as much orange juice as we
want or at least any of the amounts that
i've listed right over here and it also
takes into the cost of
maybe some employees who are spending
some of their time operating this super
orange juice mixer so i'm assuming all
of those are fixed costs that i can't
get out of them or buy them overnight
that i've decided i've plunked down the
cost for the machine and i've given
these employees let's say i've given
them already a one-year contract so
these are going to be fixed at least for
the next year
now my variable costs here these are
going to be given the amount of juice i
want to produce this is going to be the
cost of the oranges and i guess we could
also say the cost of transporting the
oranges and so we see here obviously if
we produce no oranges we have no
variable cost if we produce a thousand
oranges then our cost of the oranges and
transporting them is five hundred
dollars if we produce two thousand it's
eight fifty and something interesting
happened our incremental variable cost
right over here went was only three
hundred and fifty dollars for the first
thousand orange it was 500 and then the
next thousand it was only 350. and so
what's happening here is i probably got
some economies i probably got some
negotiating power now with some of these
suppliers
i'm like look i'm buying two i'm buying
a lot more oranges now let me negotiate
the price down and also maybe with some
of the people who are doing my shipping
my transportation look i'm shipping a
lot
now now why don't you give me a better
deal and we see the deal got even better
the incremental from this to this is
only 250 and then it starts getting more
expensive again and what's probably
happening is as i start buying more and
more oranges from the local distributors
i get a better better deal they view me
as a bigger and bigger customer but once
i tap them out then i have to go further
and further away so maybe it's costing
more to transport them or maybe these
other suppliers don't take me as
seriously or i go to slightly more
expensive suppliers because i've tapped
out all of the cheap ones and so my my
incremental variable cost for the next
thousand and we'll think about that
later keeps going up and up and up and
the total costs obviously are just the
sum of my fixed costs and my variable
costs so if i want to produce 9 000
gallons of orange juice it's going to
cost me
three hundred and sixty dollars so let's
calculate using i'm just using excel
here
let's calculate the average fixed cost
so we don't want to divide by zero so
remember the average cost the average
fixed and the average variable in the
average total cost these are each of
those costs divided by the total amount
of juice that i'm producing or you can
kind of view them as the cost per gallon
so that we're thinking of the average
fixed cost per gallon so what we're
going to do so i'm writing equal to let
excel know that i'm doing a formula now
this is going to be equal to my fixed
cost divided by
so divided by
divided by
my gallons and you can see that's g8
divided by f8 and actually i guess you
can't see my g's at f's but this is the
eighth row so that's
that right over there so that is one
dollar and then if i want my average
variable cost that's going to be
my variable cost divided by
divided by my total number of gallons so
that's 50 cents so that the first
thousand gallons to produce the orange
ju the or the orange juice for or to
produce a gallon it cost me about 50
cents worth of oranges
if and that includes the transportation
cost and then the total is just the the
sum of these two things or we could have
done it another way we could have taken
this right we could have said that this
is just equal to
this is just equal to our total cost
our total costs divided by
the total number of gallons either way
you'll get the same thing and you could
maybe i'll do a video mathematically on
why that is or maybe you should explore
that yourself
now the marginal cost this is equal to
our change in cost our change in total
cost divided by our change in gallons of
juice so our change in total cost is
going to be 1500
minus
1000 that's our change in total costs
divided by our change in gallons divided
by 1000 minus
0 our change in gallons
and that gives us 50 cents
and now and this is the fun thing about
spreadsheets one of the many fun things
of spreadsheets is now i can select all
of these and fill in all of the things
below it and they will use the same
relative calculations
so that let me just i'm going to fill
without formatting and what was neat
here and i already set up this chart
ahead of time is to plot these things
right over here and so we see what's
going on so this is a plot that we
looked at in the last video when we
talked about thought about software
developers this was our fixed cost our
variable costs go up as we produce more
and more our total cost is just the sum
of the two so you just take your
variable cost and you add the thousand
dollars from the fixed cost and you get
this curve right over here what we've
done here is we've plotted all of this
stuff the average fixed cost or actually
the marginal cost the average variable
cost and the average total cost i
haven't plotted the average fixed cost
here but it's really just the difference
between the total and the variable cost
now let's think about what's happening
so first let's look at the average the
marginal actually let's look at the
marginal cost first because this is
interesting and this kind of goes in
with this narrative of at first those
first oranges that we bought were
expensive we weren't a major producer
but incrementally that incrementally as
we produce that those next oranges so as
we go from 1000 orange as we go from the
the orange is needed for 1 000 gallons
to the oranges needed for 2 000 gallons
all of a sudden our marginal cost went
down we are now a bigger buyer we can
now those incremental oranges are now
cheaper to us and as we get even more as
we go to 3 000 gallons worth of oranges
those incremental oranges get even
cheaper for us and then we have to go
and buy oranges from the outside so
those incremental oranges get more and
more and more and more expensive and
that's most clear in this marginal cost
curve and it's somewhat clear in the
average the average variable cost and in
the average variable cost it gets
muffled to a certain degree because
remember the average variable cost at
any one of these points and we
calculated it already several times the
average variable cost at any of these
points is equal to
is equal to your variable cost divided
by the gallons of juice so another way
to think about it referring to the last
video if you're taking any one of these
points your average variable cost is the
slope between that point and the origin
while the marginal cost is the slope
between that point and the previous
point so the marginal cost is really
showing how much are those next
incremental oranges costing you not just
how much are all of the oranges on
average costing you so that's why the
marginal cost curve captures captures
how much those you know that very next
set of a thousand gallons worth of
oranges how much that is costing you and
obviously your average total cost at
first you have your fixed costs aren't
being spread out too much but then as
you have higher as you get more and more
gallons of orange juice produced your
fixed costs get spread out more and more
and more and so you actually have this
gap this gap between the green curve and
the orange curve which is really your
average fixed cost that becomes lower
and lower and lower